hi everybody I'm Lacey from the Parker
Institute and this has been and will be
co-presenting
switching back and forth and we're going
to tell you about building a unified
cancer immunotherapy data library so
this project has been a collaboration
it's still ongoing between the parker
institute for cancer immunotherapy where
I work and cognate echt
where Ben works and the project we call
candle which stands for the cancer data
and evidence library and what candle is
is it's a unified data ecosystem for
cancer immunotherapy data and a bunch of
associated tooling so we have tooling to
import data into the system without
writing any code we have tooling to
query the data from our and return
native our data structures and we have a
lot of extensions to the system that
enable analysis visualizations and more
so our talks gonna have three parts
first I'll tell you about the field of
cancer immunotherapy sort of where the
field is right now the data problem
we're facing and why we built this
system then Ben and I will tell you
about our solution for data storage and
import and then again Ben and I will
tell you about our solution for data
access so I wanted to start with a quick
personal story of what brought me into
this field most people in this room have
probably been touched by cancer in some
way or another my own personal
experience started 3 years ago when I
was diagnosed with stage 4 non-hodgkins
lymphoma as far as cancer diagnoses go
this is a pretty good one to get really
as far as good as you can get
thanks to chemotherapy and a very early
immunotherapy called rituximab cure
rates for my type of lymphoma are about
75% so after about six months of
treatment going through some fun stuff
like losing my hair I went into
remission I'm still in remission now and
this experience turned out to be a
really positive thing for me because it
transitioned it made me want to
transition into the field of cancer
research so my background is in data
science and machine learning applied to
biological data so it actually wasn't a
crazy move to go into
Cancer Research so I talked to pretty
much every company doing something with
oncology and data in the Bay Area and I
ended up at a place called the Parker
Institute so the Parker Institute for
cancer immunotherapy is a non-profit our
mission is pretty bold it is to
accelerate the development of
breakthrough immune therapies to turn
cancer into a curable disease the
Institute was founded about three years
ago from a large grant from Sean Parker
and we have a network of scientists
around the country we have sites at
seven cancer centers and our efforts are
wide-ranging everything from running
clinical trials based on research by our
researchers to collaborative research
projects to efforts at things like
technology standardization and data
standardization across the field and
that's where this project comes in so to
start talking about what immunotherapy
is it's helpful to look at the history
of cancer treatment so the first things
that humans kind of did to try to treat
cancer were surgery and radiation so in
the 19th century and early 20th century
surgery and radiation were the only
options and these work well for local
tumors but not so well if cancer spread
throughout the body next came
chemotherapy which is very exciting
because it was the first thing that
could be administered as a drug and
systemically go through a patient's body
and kill cancer in all corners of the
body
however chemotherapy targets any cell
that's dividing which is cancer cells
but it's also things like your hair
cells and the lining of your digestive
tract so chemotherapy has a lot of
really toxic unpleasant side effects and
it doesn't produce long lasting cures in
most cancers next came targeted drugs
which work for very specific cancers and
then only in the past 10 years has this
kind of revolution in immunotherapy come
about so immunotherapy is any therapy
that uses the body's own immune system
to treat cancer
it works on non-local tumors like chemo
does many types of cancers
it has a lower toxicity than
chemotherapy generally and it works well
in conjunction with other therapies but
the most exciting advance and
immunotherapy is that in some subsets of
patients we see really long lasting
responses that look like cures and this
is something that it really exceeds what
we've seen with chemotherapy and that's
what makes it such a promising area so
there are many types of immunotherapy
and I won't go into all the details but
to give you an overview the kind of
biggest and the first class of
immunotherapy is are called checkpoint
inhibitors so the body's immune system
is naturally able to kill tumors but
tumors can evolve to stop the immune
system so what checkpoint inhibitors do
is they sort of put a brick under the
brake pedal so that the tumor can no
longer stop the immune system from
attacking it
another class is cellular therapies so
an example you may have heard of in the
news is Carty therapies so these are
really cool therapies where you remove
immune cells from a patient's body
Yury engineer them in some way to be
better at treating cancer and then you
put them back in the patient and these
have only been approved in the past two
years or so and another really broad
class of therapies is immune enhancers
that kind of generally up the body's
ability to fight and deal with cancer
all of these therapies are working in a
very complex environment of hundreds of
types of immune systems extremely
diverse tumor environments and so
there's a lot to figure out in trying to
improve these therapies the state of the
field right now is that there as of july
2019
there are almost 4,000 immunotherapy
drugs at various stages of drug
development there are over 2,000 active
clinical trials in just one type of
checkpoint inhibitor the most common
type so what we're hoping is
that with a really really developing
data infrastructure in the field and our
approach to data that we can get to a
more informed approach so right now the
field kind of looks like the early days
of chemotherapy where we kind of just
want to try all the things and we want
to try all the combinations of all the
things and see what it works and it kind
of looks like this right and we're
hoping that with a better more
data-driven approach we can at least
make it look a little more like that so
what kind of data are we talking about
here so as patients go through clinical
trials and sometimes standard treatments
they often researchers will collect
blood samples and tumor samples from the
patient and there are a wide range of
different biological assays that we can
run on these samples to see what's going
on inside the patient so these range
from tumor immune imaging to get
detailed images of tumors to sequencing
and gene expression to look at the
mutational landscape of the tumor to t
cell sequencing see specifically which T
cells are in the patient immune
profiling again looking at different
immune subtypes in even more detail and
a wide variety of other biological
assays and emerging technologies and
this field is really growing every day
contributing to what we can measure now
when we combine this with the clinical
data from the patient's things like
their age and what therapy they got and
whether they're responding to the
treatment
this basically creates a whole lot of
data and this data is extremely complex
so if I'm biological data scientist
trying to analyze this data and learn
something helpful for the field what
does my job look like so I'll start with
sort of big raw data files straight off
a sequencing machine saying and then
there's a lot of processing that's
needed to get this to some kind of
tabular format some table of
measurements that says things like this
gene had this level of expression the
next step as with most data is analysis
to get you to some kind of insight so an
insight and immunotherapy sounds
alphabet soup sounds like pd-1 is higher
in Fox p3 positive cd4 t-cells and
patients who respond to PT one therapy
this this insight is an interesting one
in the field and so the next thing you
would want to do if you found this
insight would be to interpret it in the
context of existing knowledge you would
want to look in other datasets see if
you observed the same thing look at
related ideas and see if those were
popping up in your data set and from
there you would form a hypothesis and
then you'd want to go back to your data
and do more analysis right so what we're
trying to do with candle is to build a
system that facilitates this
interpretation loop so in designing a
system to support this interpretation
workflow sort of what are the issues
we're tackling so first of all data
tends to be physically fragmented within
and outside organizations so there in
any organization may be multiple
internal databases there are many public
data sources that are separate from each
other and then there's actually a lot of
useful information buried in Excel
tables in the supplements of published
papers which is basically dark matter as
far as any analyst is concerned so the
data is physically fragmented but
aggregating it all into one place isn't
really enough right a pile of data is
useless no matter how big the pile is or
put another way a pile of data does not
spark joy and this is because the data
is conceptually fragmented too right it
doesn't have a unified schema it doesn't
have a unified semantics so putting it
all in one place is really just a tiny
step if you want to if you're not
convinced about the dangers of
conceptual Samantha semantics
standardization you can think about this
paper from this article from two years
ago in science saying one in five
genomics papers has errors thanks to
Microsoft Excel because there's a gene
called s EPT too and Microsoft Excel
reformats that
as to SEP so this is the importance of
intelligence and unified semantics so to
give you just a tiny example of what I
mean by physically and conceptually
fragmented data you can take a look at
these four tables which could be tables
from the analysts on four different
clinical trials you can see the data has
separate schema right every column
header is different even for the same
concept like a subject ID but more
importantly it's it has different
semantics across the tables in one table
we see melanoma in the other table we
see more specific kinds of melanoma in
once in the orange table under treatment
we see an type II v1 which is actually
the general class of drugs that in the
yellow table we see therapy nivo so
those are conceptually similar but we
have no way of knowing that from this
representation and two of our last
challenges that we're trying to overcome
here are the scientists who are working
with this data need to be biological
data experts they need to be experts in
things like immunology and epidemiology
and cancer biology and also in analyzing
data so we can't expect them to also be
data engineers and lastly we really want
to function as a team we want to be able
to write analysis code and then reuse it
tomorrow and break away from the
academic model of doing analysis on my
project by myself at my computer and
then putting all my code in an archive
folder at the end of the project and
never looking at it again so our goal
with Candle is to put the data at the
scientists fingertips by aggregating all
of our data with a unified schema
developing tools to bring any data set
into the system and enabling downstream
applications whether computer driven or
human driven and our design requirements
for doing this our system needs to
support human reasoning our data model
needs to capture the high early
relational nature of the data the schema
needs to be able to accommodate change
as we learn because our knowledge of
biology is constant
evolving and any insight that we get
from the data must be reproducible to
enable us to do good science so now I'm
going to hand it over to Ben to talk
about how we went about solving these
problems the system especially as
closest to and makes the most use of
date I'll make this is when you know
Congress act and I come in because David
Tomic was an ideal fit for the
constraints and the requirements that I
see outlined and this is my partnership
I'm not going to say that economic is
the only way to achieve these kinds of
properties in a system especially for a
smartie it's a very high leverage system
here you ensure that a lot of these
things game of flexibility and
reproducibility the ability to query the
data quickly and effectively have
meaningful structured query that these
are all invariants that are voiced
through the database rather than things
that you're constantly having to build
and maintain elsewhere in the system so
this problem landscapes also not unique
to the Parker Institute or the cancer
mission falls into a broad category of
data science problems around just
getting the data right if you look at
big company data science teams and their
engineering blogs and so on you see this
come up a lot yes a lot of recent
advances and so on are due to machine
learning
algorithms improving when people are
writing at post-mortems on their biggest
bugs it's always like Oh something in
the data was wrong the biggest source of
these things the wrong conclusions
production bugs etc is data that's
mislabeled or was omitted by mistake or
was included by mistake or didn't
conform to some schemas or wasn't used
you knew about X you couldn't include it
in the analysis or you lost some aspect
of granularity of it going from storage
data storage B to understand how the
atomic fits here it's going to make
sense especially for anybody who's not
familiar with it for me to be a little
bit of data on the quota once stuff I'm
going to move through that fairly
quickly you know there'll be video for
people to review this stuff was a little
bit too fast but it's important to
understand the kind of representations
they're indeed comic so here we have our
you know disparate bag of tables and
they're you know there are trade-offs to
the types of representations that we
choose if we start off with at house
schemas and tables based on my
particular data science workflow or the
instrument that I used if we're working
with relational tables and fully
normalized schema were working with
denormalized data and a key value store
like no sequel context all of these
things have different constraints and
affordances now in the atomic the most
primitive way to represent things is at
the level of an individual fact and an
individual fact the core component of it
is that we have an entity we have an
attribute and a value so for some
particular thing we know something about
that so we know about this particular
subject that they have disease and that
particular disease
mmm cancer now of course we have eight
multiple facts some of those facts may
be about the same entities or about this
particular subject we know they have an
ID as well and they have a particular
therapy that was tried and if you've
worked with molten data in the law or
already have a triple stores you've seen
this kind of data before where de Tomac
is different as we also track the
accumulation of things that we know over
time so I've used two transaction time
stamp here it's actually a transaction
enstein which can have more information
on it
but we also track with that not only was
it at this particular point in time but
something either was asserted or it was
retracted so we can you know cancel out
previous knowledge to track exactly when
those things took place and this is more
than fully expanded data and economics
Dana model now from facts as datums we
can project out entities or things that
are more like objects or documents
depending on which context and language
you'd like to use and you'll see here
the relation that we have in Steve's and
attributes and values in each of those
pairs we've pulled and do a single in
Steve Matt appear so now we have one
coherent entity to deal with elsewhere
in the dataset the other detail life is
sort of a light and thus far is that
there are reference types if you look at
the attribute therapy now and if you
look at the original entity that I had
called subject before these have been
replaced with integer types and you can
see that we're actually relating
entities to other entities the
attributes therapy points to another
entity and there are other properties on
that entropy sorry on that entity
as well and any reference like this is a
first-class attribute anatomic that you
can do bi-directional traversal and this
is what enables some of the cool
relational rejoins stuff and some of the
graphing link qualities of diatomic as a
database now real Thetas models of
course get more nuanced you end up with
a lot more edges relations because it
turns out we have more properties you
want to aggregate at different levels
you know it's not only do I relate to
this thing but in what way do I link to
that into that relation like other
relations that other thing is how and
these sort of things build out the
complexity of the data model a little
bit the important point here is that the
datums and the entities projected from
the data aspect of detail make scales to
these different contexts so this
primitive representation still is the
same thing that's being in used for this
more complex and more data rich example
now so if we go back here to our
physically and conceptually fragmented
data now if you've tried to do this kind
of mugging in a data science environment
before we're just working directly with
a relational database you know kind of
what the night next step might look like
right suddenly I have a new table when
it's got a bunch of holes in there and
I've got some periodic steps need to do
maybe I have to replace values maybe I
can infer things based on similarities
to other things or by rounding up the
data and of course the atomic doesn't
solve things that you just don't know
but the actual story for this is a
little uglier to write because I have
things alighted but of course you have
nulls if you're lucky you might end up
with another no data value that came
from some data scientists workflow and
suddenly you've got negative nine nine
nine nine point nine everywhere and
you're not sure why that's there and
it's probably a missing value and you
hope that you catch it before it gets
automatically scaled from zero to one by
some other tool that you're running
that's clipping values that are out of
range and to get this stuff to work in
the first place you know you've probably
copied some magical incantation from
another data scientist and it had left
and right and inner and outer all over
the place and you're not necessarily
sure where you may have ended up with
duplicate entity entities or where
things might have been flattened
we can just skip this whole process
doing things directly in targeting
datums we can see each of these cells
instead as individual facts that are
asserted or sometimes retracted about
entities and flatten them to the flat
schema and atomic and from there we can
make this question of how do we
visualize this which things do we care
about etc a problem for query and a
problem for projecting things via poll
or other means from the basic primitives
datums and yes that means we can take
these things and project them out to
tables if we want to if that's what
makes sense sorry skipper that was
before the other thing we can do you
know when I was talking about all these
things maybe we had filler values maybe
we had imputed things to get values in
the first place to do some kind of
analysis a lot of these decisions get
made at various different points in a
data science workflow you might have
done them in our before you push the
data to the database you might have done
it in some view that then later got
turned into a table and reasserted for
your data of record in de Tomic we can
start deciphering these little data
science history puzzles overtime by
using it as a system of record so each
of these datums again there are things
that accumulate over time and it helps
us tackle lots of important aspects of
analytical reproducibility yeah so the
full history is always there and we can
always recreate a database as of a
particular point in time to see why we
answered a question in a certain way and
the timestamp information on these
slides also isn't quite right because
you could have like I mentioned before
this is really a transaction entity and
I could annotate things like which
workflow did this come from
which analysis toolkit did this come
from which instrument collected this
data and even if we don't necessarily
capture all that directly in the schema
the data scientists are touching all the
time if we discover a problem and one of
those pre-existing pipe lines that's
outside of the atomic system we can
track down everything that created that
yeah so operationally there's a lot more
to this of course people that have
worked with relational databases are
asking well what are the indexes and are
they actually efficient to touch even if
you can see all these things the answer
is yes this stuff is efficient and going
into all those details is too long for
this talk but the important thing is all
of these details enable those details to
be alighted and not included and
abstracted away so that downstream when
people are doing things in are when
they're preparing data we can make sure
that they don't have to worry about
those aspects of day Tomic the atomic is
just something behind a system that they
happen to be using so it's just some
operational detail it's not something
you know they're touching it every day
but they're not thinking you know day
Tomek the atomic the atomic because
that's one again on one of the primary
values one of the primary use context
here is that we want the tool to be used
by data scientists by doctors by people
doing biomedical research they're
frequently not software engineers they
might be good programmers but they're
not doing distributed systems work or
database development per se they're
doing a lot of really you know maybe
hard to understand things to do in their
own domain with tables and data frames
and similar things like that in our so
what we've done as part of this
partnership is we've developed again
this is all part about how to get stuff
into des Tomic in the first place and
we've developed an importer that
facilitates this so the importer is
called pret and it allows a user to
specify a mapping from tables and their
own structured data into and whatever
sorry whatever schema they happen to use
when they created it or that was you
know brought to their project elsewhere
and to map that into a common data model
in the candle database there are a lot
of details here and a little bit Lacy's
gonna walk through or real example of
this but they're you know the important
things are making sure we can map from
different types of terminology to others
and that's that's where ontology is come
in and are used by the system
we also want to make sure that we
preserve the right level of granularity
so that if we make a decision to group
something one way today we can possibly
make a decision to group it differently
later and we also want to allow this to
be as data-driven but also flexible so
we call it programmable sometimes it's
programmable like in a declarative sense
you can do a lot of non-trivial things
with the data structure that the data
scientists have access to so the last
little piece I'm going to talk about in
the implementation details here so
there's an additional data layer we've
provided now the atomic has its own data
layer about the things that are going
into it and that's the atomic schema and
it tracks information like which things
are references which things are strings
and so on which things have to be unique
across all entities at which things can
point are you know many references so
they can refer to many other things and
which fields can only refer to singular
values we've added an additional layer
on top of this that enforces our own
constraints and provides leverage for
the things we want it to and that's
called the metamodel and the metamodel
is basically schema annotations as data
and atomic so we track for instance what
kinds of things are in the database
which things refer to each other is
there some kind of component or parent
relationship between those things and if
so what direction is it and this kind of
model derives the structure of the
config so if you look at this
configuration file here we see data set
pointing to subjects which points to
therapies which has a field that points
to you know how to map an ID about those
things the structure of this file and
these different details sorry this is
all determined by the metamodel and
data-driven based on the current
contents of the atomic database it's not
explicitly programmed in code so that
theoretically that means that you could
adapt this to different domains if
enough of the data shape was similar in
our context it means we're able to
operate
where we iterate very quickly on schema
changes because we don't have to rewrite
a bunch of new code to do it you just
have to update the schema contents and
then that drives the rest of the ETL
process so it turns out this is you know
a very general system now sorry I think
I talked about everything I was supposed
to talk about on the slide on the last
one so I'll go ahead and skip that so
there are a few things that are kind of
more schema specific this is all about
downstream validation in this case it
uses a combination of de Tomic queries
and closure spec to ensure that there's
you know referential integrity between
things that all the values make sense
that things are within some biologically
plausible range a common error that this
catches is somebody scaled something to
a different set of values and they were
supposed to and so we catch these kinds
of things fairly quickly and somebody
goes back and fixes the data and this
kind of thing again this enables you
know we have pretty printers for errors
and so on and the tools that when people
see these problems they can iterate very
quickly on getting back and getting the
data right and you don't discover that
the analysis is wrong sometime later or
worst case after the papers published
right we're you know well ahead of that
now in terms of what you actually have
to do command line wise as a data
scientist to make use of this the
command line workflow is pretty simple
we have a command prepare transact and
validate we also have the concept of
doing this against a staging database
first and then if all of that works and
the validations pass then you can push
it into the production database and you
know the total set of arguments is
pretty low you have to know about a
working directory which is where
transaction data gets created and you
have to know about add atomic config
which tells you how to talk to a
particular de Tomek database and again
for the production database workflow you
have to log in and go through you know
oh ah handshake and then be able to push
your working directory once the
transaction data is definitely good up
so it can get incorporated after review
into a production database
okay so from here I'm going to turn it
back to lacy so I've talked about the
technical details of how this works
she's going to go through a real example
and real analysis case
so as been described are dated virtually
and in fact are scheming agnostic except
for the validation component one of the
powerful assurances candle is that we
have created a unified schema for
answering or therapy data and I won't go
through the details of the schema but
another powerful part of it is that in
the schema and also a reference data
that we've loaded into the database we
have domain semantics with ontologies
for genus protein cell types diseases
drugs adverse events there are a lot of
pathologies in this space and we've
tried to connect to as many of them as
possible and we have the ability to add
corners together so to walk through a
specific example I wanted to tell you
quickly about one of those clinical
trials that we've run at the Parker
Institute so this clinical trial is
called prints which stands for something
very long it's a clinical trial in
pancreatic cancer which is a really high
need area and the clinical trial
combines chemotherapy with a novel type
of immunotherapy so in pancreatic cancer
with the baseline chemotherapy in this
study the overall response rate so that
means the fraction of patients who in
this therapy see a significant shrinkage
of their tumors is 23% from the large
phase 3 study that had this combination
approved in our study is it's only been
very small so far and this data is only
from 24 patients but right now we're
seeing a response rate after phase 1 B
of 54 percent so overall this is much
improved from basic chemotherapy
response rates and even more excitingly
in many of our patients who have been on
therapy now for a year year and a half
we're seeing a durable continued
response so we're following up on this
right now in a larger phase 2 study but
I wanted to tell you about some of our
analysis on the phase one and how candle
was incorporated so at the Parker
Institute one of our missions is
to learn as much as we can biologically
from every clinical trial that we've run
so on all of our patients for this trial
we collected tumor and blood samples and
we ran a large array of biological
assays on the samples ranging from tumor
immune imaging to sequencing and
cytometry and cell-free DNA in the blood
and more and then we combined all of
this with the clinical data from these
patients and we loaded it all into
Candle so the steps in doing this is
first to take all of this data and
process it into a useful tabular format
so if you think back to that what is the
data scientist job look like that I
talked about in the beginning first you
have to get it into a table of
measurements and this we do using a lot
of other infrastructure that we've built
at the Parker Institute and external
tools that I won't talk about today but
once we have it all in useful table
format that's when we prepare config and
we can load it into Candle so this is I
know you can't read this but this is a
simplified version of what the import
config looks like for this data set so
zooming in on specific parts so the very
top level is just information about the
import it's telling me who's importing
it where can I find my mappings file
what's the name of the import next we
get into the actual biological data so
as Ben said the structure of the config
is directly driven by the structure of
the schema and metamodel so we have our
top level data set entity which has
attributes of name you can see the name
of the study and then assays and the
assays are where the actual biological
data comes in so here we have an assay
measuring cell free DNA we have an
attribute with its technology
description and in this assay we have a
couple measurements sets and when we get
down here to actual measurements the
data is no longer written directly into
the config but is instead fed in through
a file so this is a data file that we've
gotten by processing the data it tells
me for each sample what is a cell-free
DNA measurement in it and you can see
that I have the input file here and then
columns in the input file on the right
map to attributes on the measurement
entity on the left and you'll notice
that each measurement references a
sample entity so the next part in the
config is the actual sample data so this
is also fed in with an input file with
one line per sample entity and
information about the sample like what
patient it came from what visit it came
from etc and this is where Pretz
knowledge of the meta model of the
schema and reference resolution magic
kind of come in so up here I had in my
measurements file references to samples
right but pret needs to turn this into
from IDs in a file in a column to
attributes on entities that reference
other attributes so the sample entity on
measurement is actually a reference to a
sample entity so prêt takes care of
resolving that identifying which sample
entity I'm referring to and then
inserting that as data into the database
and from there we go on to the rest of
the config which houses the clinical
data all of the other assay data the
other biological data such as
information about the subjects and what
therapies they received and pret has a
lot of other machinery for dealing with
things like missing data and reverse
references and a lot of other details
we're not going into so now we've
processed the data we've made the config
and as Ben mentioned the steps to
importing data are preparing and then
transacting and then validating so as a
user my experience is that first I run
prepare and then I'm going to get back a
bunch of errors that are gonna tell me
you know this range is supposed to be
zero to one and you told me it was 77 or
you know this gene needs to look like
this format and it looks like this
format things like that then when I've
taken care of those I'll run transact
and then prep will tell me oh you
referenced this variant but that variant
doesn't actually exist in the database
so I can't I can't put that in and then
I'll go fix those errors and then lastly
all run validate which is where I get
the most complex errors that really have
to do with multi entity validations
and by the time I've gone through this
entire process my data is fully in the
right format and fully validated so the
end result here is the data is fully in
the candle schema it's been mapped and
numerous domain ontology x' and it's
passed a lot of validations that have
made sure that the data is correct and
usable downstream and so from here we
know that our downstream analyses will
be more correct more usable and more
reproducible we've been working on
loading data into candle as we've been
building it and this is kind of our
progress so far so a lot of this is
public published data some of it is our
own trial data some of it is our
collaborators data but so far we have
almost 40,000 samples from almost 25,000
subjects in 33 cancer types across nine
biological technologies and about 570
million measurements and this has been
work by the entire informatics team at
the Parker Institute who have been using
pret as it's been developed and really
finding all of the bugs in early
versions of the software and giving us a
lot of helpful feedback so now Ben is
gonna tell us about now that our data is
in the database our tooling for
accessing and analyzing it and we're
pretty tight timeline so I'm gonna go
fairly quickly through this so take
screenshots of slides later I guess so
the big thing is there are other closure
projects out there that say we're going
to reinvent data science and closure
this isn't that talk in this case we
decided to meet the data scientists
where they were in the our environment
so that means providing tooling so that
they can do queries and our mostly we
hide the fact that it's de Tomic from
them but one area where this is
different is we believe that data log
provides a lot of power and simplicity
to their workflow so we want to give
them access to use the atomic data log
directly in the our environment and the
way we do that is by serializing queries
over plain JSON data now if you've
looked at des Tomic before you probably
see in various different queries there
are a lot of different you know where
clauses different values that show up
here and there
the most important thing that we have to
sort of disambiguate on a parser you
know lexer pass or however you want to
think about it is most of these cases
aren't that bad right if it starts with
a question mark its variable if it
starts with a call and it's a keyword
and most of the time you know you don't
have real literal data that starts with
those things and if you do you can
provide some kind of escape you do have
to have some structural awareness so
that if you have a plain string that's
supposed to be a function call or an
aggregate or something you can
disambiguate that from a constant
literal it turns out you can do this
with spec and specs own collection
oriented regular expressions and you can
just take the BNF like grammar from the
diatomic query Docs and turn that into
your parser and that's what I did in
this case so you have a plain JSON way
of serializing queries to a service that
then runs them in there and you said you
don't have any additional dependencies
on the our side so using stuff from our
directly this is what it looks like
you've got a very kind of lightweight
thing that looks like just using des
Tomic and not passing a plain string
query or something like that to it so
you can actually you know do substantive
you know feedback or validation on the
query before you send it if you want to
this has enabled a lot of downstream
applications we have Mike Travers
actually in the audience right now it's
building a visual query builder against
this system we have interactive
visualization tools that are being
worked on on the our side and so on all
taking advantage of the fact that you
can get data structure level
manipulation just over playing Jason
today to log queries all right back to
you Lacey
okay so just to wrap up I wanted to walk
you through our tooling for plotting an
analysis from this point and a couple of
example analyses that we've done and
we're over time so I'll I'll try to go
quick too so from the candle database
the first thing that we built is a
package called wick so this is an R
package that has our query DSL and also
a bunch of standard pre-canned queries
like get me all the gene expression
measurements for example with wick we
can execute queries like show me the cd8
T cell infiltration in non-metastatic
biopsies for patients receiving new
volume map which is a meaningful
question if you're analyzing this kind
of data that our query looks
approximately like this and then if I
run that to a query server with WIC I
can get back a native our data frame
like this which is now in the format
that most of our data scientists are
used to and is now ready for analysis so
additionally on top of these we have
some packages we've made for plotting
and analysis we have a package called
luminance which has a bunch of standard
plots and glow for interactive data
exploration and these are tools that
we're constantly building on as we're
doing analysis and with these you can
really easily make plots that compare
features by patients and groups or look
at immune cells in the blood over time
or look at the landscape of mutations in
your set of patients or other things you
might want to do like that
so going back to the prints trial that I
told you about I want to tell you about
two pieces of analysis that we did on
this trial which we did execute fully
from candle so these results were
presented at a ACR
earlier this year one example result
that we presented was on tumor immune
imaging so what you're seeing here is an
image of a tumor and each of these
little colored dots is a tumor and or an
immune cell and the different colors
represent different kinds of cells so
after processing this data and loading
it into candle we can really easily do
things like look at the
distribution of different immune cell
types across the patients and see that
actually these samples were fairly high
in macrophages which is a target of one
of the immunotherapies that we were
using another analysis that we did on
this data set from candle is involving
circulating tumor DNA so this is DNA
that's escaped from the tumor and is
circulating through the bloodstream you
can get it with a blood draw from the
patient and we were looking specifically
at mutations in a gene called K wrasse
in the circulating tumor DNA so after
loading this data which came from our
collaborators at UPenn using an assay
they developed we loaded it into Candle
along with the tumor measurements from
all the patients and then could easily
look at them side-by-side and observe
that each of these plots is a patient
the red lines you can see their tumors
shrinking the red lines of the tumors
and in patients who saw shrinkage in
their tumors we tended to see a
corresponding decrease in the chaos
mutations in the blood and this is an
interesting finding because lower chaos
mutations in the blood could in theory
be an early indicator of a response that
doesn't involve something like a PET
scan so we did these and many many more
analysis on this data and others and the
really important thing to emphasize here
is that with Candle providing the state
standard data interface and WIC and
luminance providing this canned plotting
code we now can reuse this entire
analysis extremely easily so we can take
this and we can follow up on these
findings by rerunning the same thing in
another data set we can I can give it to
another data scientist on our team and
he can run it on the project he's doing
and in general we can gain efficiency by
having the experts in particular data
types in areas write code that can be
used by others so to wrap up in building
Candle we've leveraged atomic enclosure
to build a unified cancer immunotherapy
data store along with tools for getting
data in and out by non closure ist's and
these tools allow us to empower the
expert
to deal with the data get efficiency
from our team the extensible and future
proof as our knowledge in the area grows
and to be reproducible in our analyses
to do good science and as this project
continues and we keep building on this
we hope that this work will enable us to
perform better research and bring
results to patients faster so as we said
at the beginning this has been a
collaborative project between the Parker
Institute and cognate echt and we wanted
to acknowledge a lot of the team that's
contributed to this so the project was
initiated by Federico Guerra Dini who
has also been involved in every step of
development the entire informatics team
has contributed to using and improving
the software on the cognitive side kirk
christiansen is our project manager and
coach keeping us organized and sane
Marshall Thompson who's right there did
a lot of the early development on pret
the data importer and then the early
design of the data importer and the
metamodel were also helped out a lot by
stu holloway and rich Hickey so thank
you very much
[Applause]